let us now revisit the subject of
expectations and develop an important
linearity property for the case we were
dealing with multiple random variables
we already have a linearity property if
we have a linear function of a single
random variable then expectations behave
in a linear fashion but now if we have
multiple random variables we have this
additional property the expected value
of the sum of two random variables is
equal to the sum of their expectations
let us go through the derivation of this
very important fact because it is a nice
exercise in applying the expected value
rule and also manipulating PMF and joint
pmfs we're dealing with the expected
value of a function of two random
variables which function if we write it
this way we are dealing with the
function G which is just the sum of its
two entries so now we can continue with
the application of the expected value
rule and we obtain the sum over all
possible XY pairs here we need to write
G of XY but in our case the function
we're dealing with is just X plus y and
then we weigh according to the entries
of the joint PMF so this is just an
application of the expected value rule
to this particular function now let us
take this sum and break it into two
pieces one involving only the X term and
another piece involving only the y term
now if we look at this double summation
look at the inner some it's a sum over
wise while we're adding over wise the
value of X remains fixed so X is a
constant as far as the sum is concerned
so X can be pulled outside this
summation
let us just continue with this term the
first one and see that a simplification
happens this quantity here is the sum of
the probabilities of the different Y's
that can go together with a particular X
so it is just equal to the probability
of that particular X it's the marginal
PMF if we carry out a similar step for
the second term we will obtain the sum
over Y's it's just a symmetrical
argument and at this point we recognize
that what we have in front of us is just
the expected value of X this is the
first term plus the expected value of y
so this completes the derivation of this
important linearity property of course
we proved the linearity property for the
case of the sum of two random variables
but you can proceed in a similar way or
maybe using the action and one can
easily establish by following the same
kind of argument that we have a
linearity property when we add any
finite number of random variables the
expected value of a sum is the sum of
the expected values just for a little
bit of practice if for example we're
dealing with this expression the
expected value of that expression would
be the expected value of 2 X plus the
expected value of 3 y minus the expected
value of Z and then using the linearity
property for linear functions of a
single random variable we can pull the
constants out of the expectations and
this would be twice the expected value
of x plus 3 times the expected value of
y minus the expected value of z
what we will do next is to use the
linearity property of expectations to
solve a problem that would otherwise be
quite difficult we will use the
linearity property to find the mean of a
binomial random variable let X be a
binomial random variable with parameters
N and P and we can interpret X as the
number of successes in n independent
trials where each one of the trials has
a probability P of resulting in a
success well we know the PMF of a
binomial and we can use the definition
of expectation to obtain this expression
this is just the PMF of the binomial and
therefore what we have here is the usual
definition of the expected value now if
you look at this sum it appears quite
formidable and it would be quite hard to
evaluate it instead we're going to use a
very useful trick we will employ what we
have called indicator variables so let
us define a random variable X I which is
a 1 if the i trial is a success and 0
otherwise
now if we want to count successes what
we want to count is how many of the x
i's are equal to 1
so if we add the x i's this will have a
contribution of 1 from each one of the
successes so when you add them up you
obtain the total number of successes so
we have expressed a random variable as a
sum of much simpler random variables so
at this point we can now use linearity
of expectations to write that the
expected value of x will be the expected
value of x1 plus all the way to the
expected value of x n now what is the
expected value of x1 it is a Bernoulli
random variable that takes the
one with probability P and takes the
value of zero with probability one minus
P the expected value of this random
variable is P and similarly for each one
of these terms in the summation and so
the final end result is equal to n times
P this answer of course makes also
intuitive sense if we have P equal to
1/2 and we toss a coin hundred times the
expected number or the average number of
heads we expect to see will be one-half
times 100 which is 50 the higher P is
the more successes we expect to see and
of course if we double n we expect to
see twice as many successes so this is
an illustration of the power of breaking
up problems into simpler pieces that are
easier to analyze and linearity of
expectations is one more tool that we
have in our hands for breaking up
perhaps complicated random variables
into simpler ones and then analyzing
them separately